okay so episode four ended with us
finding out that scarlet witch was doing
a weekend at wonders with visions dead
corpse
it was a mind-blowing moment that set
her up as the big bad
but throughout the season there's been
several clues that something more
sinister is going on behind the scenes
we're going to be breaking it all down
but as always welcome to the heavy
spoilers show i'm your host paul
aka the guy who jimmy woo's you with my
card tricks
now let's get into the bigger db kitty
breakdown now as always things are time
coded below if you want to skip
ahead but as is usual with our videos
we're going to be discussing some key
theories up top
if you've been keeping up to date with
the behind the scenes stuff on the show
then you'll know that showrunner jack
schaefer revealed that one division
actually takes place almost immediately
after end game
and before the events are far from home
if you checked out our video last week
then you'll have seen us discussing an
interview with paul bettany
in which he revealed that endgame
originally had a post-credits scene that
set up the events of the show
it was supposed to close out with wonder
going to see vision's body which was
being kept in a draw
and we can see why this was cut as it
sort of happens in the episode at one
point
vision actually didn't want to be
brought back to life but wanda doing
this shows that she has completely
broken his trust
we now know for definite that he's being
puppeted around by here and just like me
he's a guy who prefers it no strings
attached
you haven't this show now the show at
this point is tying in heavily with the
graphic novel vision and the skull at
which
which followed the pair as they moved to
the suburbs of new jersey
and had children together released in
1985
it heavily inspires this entry and
similar the show it
also carries the aesthetic that the pair
magically have children together
now whilst vision was never dead at any
point during the book
it does feature the grim reaper quite
heavily whose helmet also popped up in
episode 2.
he has the power to bring back people
from the dead and if the part about
wander taking this from the slab to the
pad is true
then it could indeed be what's going on
though our theories change every week eh
at least we're not repeating ourselves i
suppose now speaking of that intro
agnes refers to herself as auntie in
this entry
which could be a callback to the advert
for kitty litter that was called
anti-a's
i guess she would be good at advertising
that because like kitty litter
she's full of sheer no no but agnes
definitely has her eyes on the kids in
this episode
and after watching it i think it's
starting to become clear that they're
the main prize that she's after
in case you don't know in the comics
billy and tommy grew up to become the
mutant's wiccan in speed
and thus possessing these could help her
to usher in a thousand years of darkness
like 2020 all over again now just
analyzing her even further
christopher quantero davidson actually
sent me a really interesting email
which discussed how the location of the
character constantly keeps changing
and thus it is possible that she doesn't
actually live in west view at all
in the first episode when introducing
herself she tells wonder that she lives
on the right
not you're right her right however in
episode 3 we discover that herb actually
lives on the left and
beyond that is dottie's which we see in
episode two
this entry also has some ambiguity but
there are clues lies throughout that
we'll be discussing in just a bit
now due to her not having id in episode
four it is possible that
like geraldine she's not from around
here and she simply casts blame on
monica to draw attention away from her
as one of history's most hated figures
goebbels said
accuse the other side that which you are
guilty and this blame shifting could
have been done to
make her fly completely under the radar
now as for the episode itself
it boils from several sitcoms that span
the 80s and 90s including full house
family ties growing pains and family
matters
the latter is because urkel had
suspenders which we see wonder rocking
at one point
and these were also present in mork and
mindy another 80s sitcom which showcased
fashion at the time
family ties is mainly because of the way
that the lighting is used to illuminate
the set
and growing pains has one of the most
obscure references in the entire show
during the series there was a famous
couch that had a single blue cushion on
it
and this one on its own also appears in
the episode at one point
full house is also quite a meta joke is
that actually featured elizabeth olsen's
real life sisters
mary kate and ashley both of which are
twins i know i don't have to say that
for some of you
but i keep forgetting that some of my
audience have just started their 20s
and they weren't born until 2000 and
2001
which makes me feel very old anyway this
idea of twins growing up will clearly be
adopted for the show too
as we watch billy and tommy mature
making this a very fourth wall breaking
moment
so we have elizabeth olsen starring as
wonder who's raising twins
whilst satirizing the show full house
which starred
olson's real life sisters being raised
as twins
what anyway that's the main aesthetic of
the episode
but let me know if there's any deeper
cuts below
we pick up with the pair trying to get
the two babies to fall asleep
and vision remarks that he tried reading
charles darwin's the descent of man to
billy but it made him cry even harder
in this book darwin detailed that men
evolved from apes
and this idea of evolution is something
that's heavily laced throughout mutants
and the x-men one of which appears at
the end of the entry
wander is unable to put the kids back to
sleep and clearly her powers are limited
much in the same way that they were with
the stalk
though this episode really tries to
hammer home that she's the one doing
everything
the fact that she has amnesia over
what's happened makes me think that she
isn't
there's very much this idea of control
being laced throughout the show not only
in vision
but the residents of west view
themselves this could extend to wonder
who may also have someone manipulating
her i think this could clearly be
anti-agnes
who shows up not too long after this
moment she's clearly aware that they are
in a show
and actually seems to be slightly
comfortable with it rather than
terrified like the rest of the town
if you've been watching our videos
you'll know that we've theorized that
she's actually agatha harkness and the
character says she has a couple of
tricks up her sleeves
which could be a reference to her
magical abilities
the two times that the children grow
agnes is present
and it could actually be her who is the
one doing it it almost happens with the
death of sparky the dog
but wonder talks them out of aging up
which may be against agnes wishes
who wants them for herself she also
mentions ralph again
and the character has definitely become
similar to frasier's marist crane
as we hear about them almost every
episode but never actually see them
i do think that ralph is one of the big
villains that will be revealed down the
line
but obviously let me know your theories
below cut to the title sequence and this
feels like a combination of family ties
and growing pains
the first is because of the illustration
that appears to outline the family
and the latter due to the photographs
and theme song it's hilariously cheesy
in both its design
and the song in the background that
descends into just rambling by the end
of it
in it we also see vision as a baby which
we know is never the case
and this of course plays upon the idea
that the children grew up without really
having a childhood
there's also real photos of elizabeth
olsen as a teen in there
and i just think it's the funniest intro
so far
cut to monica being scanned after her
accident last week and she states that
she felt grief in the hex
and relates to this on a number of
levels due to losing her mother
now the readings taken of her are blank
and this is likely because
due to her being tossed through the hex
membrane whilst being covered in wonders
powers
that they have molded into her in the
comics moniker goes on to become a
superhero
known as photon who possesses several
abilities that we've already seen in the
hex itself
these include shape-shifting phasing
through mata
and of course flight i think that this
confirms that she is indeed a metahuman
now
and going forward to captain marvel 2 we
will likely see her full skill set
we go to sword holding a briefing in
which acting director haywood
clearly states that wonder is the issue
they go through her history including
her volunteering for hydra
and jimmy woo says it's an
oversimplification of the events
but yes that's what happened i kind of
feel like this line might be a call back
to mission impossible in which ethan
hunt says something similar
and we all know jimmy loves secret
agents and so on so meh
we're out here reaching again now
something that's quite strange is that
he says
wonder doesn't actually have a nickname
which i hadn't actually thought about up
until now
of course we all know she's called
scarlet witch so she may actually end up
getting this moniker in the season
as we know that she does dress in the
classic costume at one point
now monica does go to wonders defense
and says that she could be doing a lot
worse
but this is silenced by the footage of
her storming the sword facility
what's interesting here is that it looks
like sorta actually experimenting on
vision
and there are several people in lab
coats they may have been taking him
apart under hayward's orders
and if we look at things from another
angle wonder could have been saving her
dead husband from being weaponized by
them
they know about vision's will which
states that he didn't want to be made
into one
so clearly they were paying close
attention to him
a big question that still remains though
is how he managed to come back to life
and as mentioned earlier this may be the
grim reaper
we go back to the show and see that
billy and tommy have found a dog
which ends up being called sparky this
is actually a call back to the vision
graphic novel by tom king
in which vision and his family had a
synthesized one of the same name
sadly the pup passes away later in the
episode after eating from agnes
poisonous bush
and i swear that's not an innuendo but i
am very immature now though wonder
doesn't resurrect him
he could still come back to life in this
form though we'll just have to wait and
see
vision reads a newspaper and like all
the other ones its headline is very
mundane
depicting a local homeowner who makes
innovating recipes
this of course carries the notion that
nothing bad ever happens in west view
and that the media don't make things up
to keep people scared
it's the perfect place to live agnes
arrives and wanda doesn't mind showing
her powers in front of her
perhaps highlighting that she's
subliminally comfortable around her
likely because she's shown them before
if the theory about agnes being agatha
is true
then she could have helped her to
enhance her abilities and then together
the pair created this reality
this would explain why agnes isn't
really alarmed at any point
and seems to know what's going on whilst
the other citizens don't
jump back to the sword outpost and we
see jimmy carrying some coffee cups
that actually look like they have the
pattern on them that appears in the
credits at the end of every episode
this is probably just a bit of a fun nod
however this pattern did sort of appear
on geraldine's dress in episode 2
so it may have a deeper meaning we see
darcy jamie and monica studying the
signs behind the hex
and they deduce that she doesn't really
have the power to pull this off
but monica shuts it down by saying that
she could have taken out thanos
which yeah she could have to be fair now
the conversation moves to captain marvel
and monica quickly changes the subject
this could be taken a number of ways
and the pair may have met since the 90s
or perhaps she used the character as
abandoning her and her mother
you know how it is when you have a
friend and you haven't seen them for a
while and
you just want to play it cool well i
kind of feel like that's what's going on
here
rather than her being angry or bitter
they also realized that monika's uniform
was transformed into geraldine's outfit
and this confirms that the sword
necklace was indeed her name batch
this does show that items created in the
hex can indeed leave it
and thus it is possible that down the
line vision does
and has been made invincible once more
because of it
yes i've seen the trailers and they
realize that they can send an email in
and we cut divisions work aka the
computational services
which were last seen in the first
episode this details division
a lot of what wonder is doing and he
snaps an home out of his hypnosis
which reveals just how frightened he is
now though it seems to
point to wonder doing it norms says she
rather than her name she could of course
apply to agnes as well
and if we're right about this then we
won't look like an idiot for banging on
about this theory for the last 10
minutes
now we watch you under looking over
billy and tommy and the conversation
quickly moves to her brother pietro
similar to the two children wander and
her sibling are unidentical twins
and it is possible that the children
were brought in to plant the idea for
her to manifest the character
at the end of the episode i kind of feel
like wonder may have made a deal with
the devil and that it's had a monkey's
poor effect
so instead of bringing her true brother
back it's brought a pietro across from
an alternate dimension
aka the x-men universe using a drone
sword infiltrate the hex a wonder comes
out wearing the costume that we saw her
donning in avengers endgame
she's absolutely furious with the group
and makes it clear that as
long as they stay out of their home
they'll be absolutely fine
with all guns pointed at her she decides
to mind control all the gods
and they then turn their weapons on
hayward now else this does back up the
idea that wonder can control people's
minds
we can see their eyes glowing red which
isn't present in the town members
who seem to be under her control i know
i'm in the minority
here thinking that she's not the big bad
behind it all but i do feel like
she is being manipulated she puts a
giant red force field around the town
and this will likely mean that no drones
or members of sword can waltz in anymore
cut to the commercial and we see the
woman returning with her two kids
now it's very similar to the one shown
in episode 3 style wise
and it is possible that her children
also reflect wonders pair
using a lagos brand of paper towel she
sweeps up the mess
and this name actually calls back to the
city from the opening of civil war
so far the commercials have pulled from
stock industries
struck a hydra and this and now we can
pretty much guarantee that they all
derive heavily from large moments in
wonder's life
it's also possible that they pull from
the infinity stones as the toaster could
be in line with the mine stone
the watch dealt with time and the hydra
soap box did look like the tesseract
lagos is red similar to the reality
stone making it seem like wonder may
also be being used to create the
infinity stones once more
we see one there and her kids looking
for sparky and they then have a
conversation with the postman
again this seems completely out of
nowhere and it's pretty pointless in the
grand scheme of things
unless he is the person under witness
protection
in episode 2 agnes pretended to shoot
him and he said i'm just a messenger
and this time he says the dog is sure to
turn up
i do think that he's the one and his
scenes are hinting towards that if you
look closely enough
he also didn't appear on the board with
the ids hinting at jimmy potentially
keeping him out of the lineup
the missing dog is similar to the
missing witness protection person
and i do think that the theory lines up
now wonder seems to avoid wanting to
bring the dog back to life
and she states that she can't reverse
death making me believe that it was
actually the grim reaper that
resurrected vision and not her
this arrives and it's not too long
before he and wonder have a
confrontation
in their home though it was absolutely
hilarious how
rather than having a difficult talk
wanda just started to roll the credits
and this was one of the best ways to use
the sitcom device that i think we've
seen so far
vision is furious that wanda seems to be
doing all this
and i actually think that he will break
free of this puppeting at some point
this could be a slight nod to ultron who
in the mcu was very much created
something to be controlled himself
but he managed to break his bonds ultron
was of course vision's creator
so it could be very much a like father
like sun pattern here
in terms of evolution in avengers age of
ultron the villain of course did the big
monologue about how there were no
strings on him
and even the credits of the show seem to
link in with his mainframe tackling
jarvis
who of course was also brought across in
vision
thus it could be being set up here that
sword will also view him as a killer bot
that they have to take down before it
carries out another sokovia level event
tensions escalate and vision goes
absolutely crazy
but wonder manages to bring him down by
reminding him that he's bullying tommy's
father
however things go further into this when
vision realizes that there's no
other children in west view oneness
slowly starts to question why he feels
like she's in control of everything
and she says she doesn't even know how
things got like this in the first place
rather than resetting time though
whoever is behind the show throws a
curveball
at her with the arrival of evan peters
now this is sort of a call back to the
vision and scholar which graphic novel
as in that she opened the door to find
her father there
however here it's her brother and i
think darcy spoke for the entire
audience
when she said they recast petrol huh
now this obviously opens up a lot of
questions including why he's not aaron
taylor johnson's version
wanda seems lost but she goes along with
it and hugs him
likely meaning that we will be getting
more surprises down the line
now is possible that due to
quicksilver's speed that he was actually
able to run fast enough to break through
the multiverse
similar to the flash however he may have
also been brought across by agnes
mephisto
but now we know that the x-men can
officially come into this universe
and i wouldn't be surprised if we
weren't getting more of them down the
line
which i'll be talking about in the leaks
section of the video
as for the episode itself i genuinely
feel like this gets better
each and every week i was a bit unsure
on the show after the first two episodes
as
they felt a bit difficult to get into
for me due to not really knowing the
context
or fully getting the references to the
old 50s and 60s sitcoms
i know some people loved it and others
felt the same as me
but i'm glad that everyone's just stuck
with it as it's been such a good show so
far
and it's pretty much my only reason for
living at this point
this is the definition of a slow burn
but i'm so glad that the mcu is taking
massive chances like this
as it allows them to explore new avenues
and also branch off into the wackiest
side of marvel
okay so that wraps up the episode in
general but as always we're going to be
talking some more spoilers
and leaks that have come out if you're
enjoying the video then please click the
thumbs up button and make sure you
subscribe
for coverage on the show every week also
i just want to give a huge thank you to
everyone who's helped to get our
breakdowns trending three weeks in a row
now
it just means that it's gonna be even
more depressing when they eventually
don't trend
but at least i can live in my perfect
little bubble for now until it all comes
crashing down
yay depression anyway i think most of
you probably saw that there were several
parts of episode six which were leaked
online earlier in the week
if you're watching to this point in the
video then you're the kind of person
that likes to ruin things for themselves
so we know some of the big scenes that
are coming down the line
i know they've been talked about in
depth but i'd prefer to address them
when the episode actually comes out
however i will be talking about some
similarities to some toys here without
showing images from the episode
or saying specifically what they are for
those that haven't watched them
see sometimes i can be a nice guy anyway
on the 4th of february someone actually
posted an image of both wiccan and speed
from a one division limited edition
funko pop set
this wasn't just a concept like i'll
talk about in just a bit
but it was actually shown by someone
holding it in a store
making me believe that it's legit now if
you did see the leaked footage
then you'll know that the character in
it is very similar in dress to what
speed is wearing making me think that he
could go on to inspire him
the design of speed is very similar to
the comic book iteration of quicksilver
as well
and there is potential here that the
show could set up the young avengers
down the line
though we'll just have to see now if
you've been paying attention to the
leaks around the show
you may have also seen something posted
that look like it came from any mates
in it we can see mephisto alongside
wonder and though it looked like mini
mates
were no longer gonna be mickey's mates
diamond have come out and said that this
is fake
so just be careful with the leaks and
stuff with this show as we're now at the
point where people are making stuff up
to trick the good folks like you
and your uncle kevin spoilers now what
i've heard in j i'm not your uncle yeah
don't don't ask for any birthday
presents this year especially not that
funko pop set
anyway what i've heard in general
centered around the show is that marvel
is going
to use this as a way to open up the
multiverse through the hex points that
have been popping up in every episode
they of course featured in guardians of
the galaxy as a way to travel
and also in far from home at the end
with nick fury
so they are laced through the mcu as a
way to get from one point to the other
and it does make sense that this is
going to be the way that people are
brought across
and from what i can gather spider-man 3
is massively going to open things up
and will feature many villains from
across multiple franchises
chances are you already know that but
feige also wants to bring several of the
x-men across
and lead with actors like fassbender and
mcavoy who are of course
already extremely popular amongst the
fanbase i think this is a
really smart way to handle things and it
would mean that we as viewers get to see
the actors that we know and love
getting to be part of the mcu another
thing i've always wondered is
why mutants are so hated in the marvel
universe when they're pretty much
exactly the same as the superheroes that
are loved and adored by the masses
however if they're from another world
this opens up the discord to discuss
why people might view them as refugees
not from the main dimension
and thus take an instant dislike to them
because let's be real
people are bad people now it's a really
good way to go forward with the
franchise
and have people invested i think and
weird on the street is that several of
the big name actors associated with the
fox franchise
have already been in talks with marvel
over what to do next
we know for definite that deadpool 3 is
coming soon and it just makes
so much sense to me to do it this way
elizabeth olsen earlier in the week
did tease that there was a big cameo
coming down the line that was at the
level of mark hamill in the mandalorian
but whether that's just the evan peters
one or something bigger
we don't quite know yet it could be tom
holland as i do think that the show
might set up the events of spider-man 3
due to it being the next one in this
so-called multiverse trilogy
but that remains to be seen please
please be this guy
on the other side of the door next time
she opens it anyway i'll of course keep
you informed on any of this stuff i hear
but for the meantime
i'd love to hear your thoughts on the
episode in the comments section below
as a thank you for interacting with the
video you'll be entered into a prize
draw on the 28th of february
in which we're giving away three copies
of the marvel phase three 4k box set to
our subscribers
all you have to do to be on the chance
of winning is like the video make sure
you subscribe
with notifications on and drop a comment
below with your thoughts on the episode
the winners of last month's competition
are on screen right now so that's you
then message me on twitter at
heavyspoilers if you want something else
to watch then make sure you check out
our breakdown of last week's
or this spider-man video that we've just
done
both of them are a lot of fun and if you
watch them
i love you forever without the way thank
you for sitting through the video bit a
bit of a weird ending that i don't love
you that much
but i've been paul you've been the best
and i'll see you next time yeah take
care
peace